[Music]
harmonize with me
you're shining bright I'm your place the
baby you're my
[Music]
bills hello Dominic here we are again
the temperatures are absolutely tipped
up in this studio it's fresh like a kind
of spring Day in England well lovely
yeah out in the maybe the uh the Moors
with a little Morning Dew listening to
Kate Bush do you ever um wash your face
in the morning dew what very very good
for you so what you mean grab stuff off
the grass just yes very gently
rubber on your face there well that's
beautiful and if you've seen a lot of
invertebrates insects and stuff like
that will come out in the very early
morning and they'll stick the cute
little Bottoms Up in the Air to catch
the Jew and then the Jew falls down
towards their mouth and that so they get
a little drink in the morning from the
butt to their mouth yeah they drink from
their anus
fantastic stuff maybe something that we
could uh incorporate into an episode at
some point perhaps how's the knee knee
not great if a minor storm it's tight
we've been getting a lot of very kind
advice and guidance from people have you
been taking them up on some of these
there was one that was very specific I
saw that someone sent us on the email
thank you very much please keep sending
the emails too
cast media act no friendship onion at
castmedia.com is cast with a K let's not
forget it's cash with a K now they need
someone sent us a thing Who and the
person was uh a trend physiotherapist
knows what they're talking about
and did start with you know
I haven't seen your knee
so take this as like a very general you
know thing take it on the chin take it
on the knee yeah as it were so but she
sent like diagrams and pictures and most
of the stuff is what I'm being told to
you know do by my man but it was good to
hear that confirmed by someone else
great and I suppose the thing is you're
only going to get as much better as as
much what you put into it and maybe I'm
just not doing enough well that's the
thing about things like stretching right
it's preventative meditation I think is
in some way like this I don't
necessarily feel the benefits of
meditation until I stop doing it and
it's the same with stretching if I
because when I start in the gym I'll
probably do less than five minutes of
stretching but it's a little you know
toe touch shoulder thing tricep thing if
I don't do that for two or three weeks
then maybe I'll feel it when you and I
went away to
West Virginia South Carolina North
Carolina North Carolina
you would get up probably half an hour
40 minutes before me and invariably when
I used to come out of my room walk past
your room to head downstairs you'd be in
the practice of a little morning
stretchy do you remember yeah no I still
do that dumb maybe not as much as I did
uh you know sort of every day but much
better and I don't you're you're a fan
of animals love animals
my animal my dog loves a little stretch
in the morning yeah yeah you know so I
think it's a good thing and otherwise
you're stiffen up don't you well it's
it's very rare if not like doesn't
happen at all for a dog or a cat gets up
from a seating position and doesn't do a
downward dog upward dog stretchy I like
it when cats just put one pour out as if
the try to reached to a new Galaxy
yeah so it's good a good stretch helps
and I think that's what I need to do and
also build up the power of my butt yeah
yeah you need to get a bigger ass but
we've always said that and also the
other thing to keep in mind which I'm
sure you're philosophical about as well
is we're almost dead exactly I mean you
know what I mean we are standing on a
rock flying through space at a thousand
miles an hour
only just staying out of the fireball
that we call the Sun
money is a very very small problem
but I'm still working on it good for you
should we do a Little League of Legends
update lead Earth Legends
we've still not got the graphics as
right sent us the music and you know
we've got nothing we've got no Graphics
okay nothing but I can see it and I'm
sure you guys can see it now it's like
I'll do the echo you do it okay
oh nice bills nice nice I feel like it's
like you know like a very heavy piece of
maybe metal hits a
screenshot
yeah so where are we at with that
because not only right not only have
shown in Elijah backed into a very deep
Shadow but you and I have not played
League of Legends together for what two
weeks a couple of weeks I think I don't
think I've played I did I played the new
Dr Mundo came out no and I like Dr Mundo
and uh but he's gone to the top
as I think we talked about this he's
went to the Top Lane I'm not a fan of
the Top Lane no no because I I get
killed all the time yeah I like to stay
far away and fire things at people yeah
I don't like it and amongst the three
yeah and if I'm not far away flinging
things at people I like to be in the
jungle yeah out the way are people I
like the jungle too I've been playing
the jungle as well do you have a
favorite jungle
creature
I tell you the The Little Rock things
are hard to kill they keep Crooks right
Crocs that's what they call them krugs
you are such a geek a complete geek I
now am starting to
watch the little uh non-playable
creatures in the jungle a snail a frog
what else is there is there a mouse in
the jungle but my friend from Riot Jake
hello Jake if you're listening who gave
us some skins thank you for that very
sweet uh I said is there any things that
maybe a deep dives into League of
Legends that we might not know he said
there are certain frogs that if you
stand close next to them they'll commit
suicide
they kind of get a fright and just fall
over
I wonder sometimes I play Casa yeah why
does Kaiser really suff frog
occasionally you're gonna have to ask
Jake or ask if anyone out there plays
co-star let us know why I I'm terrible
at Kate I'm just terrible at the game
but I like you as Kai star you do like
crazy but I played against Kaiser before
and she will destroy people yeah I can
never get that powerful well we'll get
there I'm you've made me excited to play
I want to play this afternoon it's like
surfing it's just like time in the water
we'll play we'll play right let's play
now where are we with Elijah
joining us on the rift where are we on a
scale scale of fruit
strawberry seeds being the smallest and
a watermelon being the top I mean yeah
I'm going to say for me a lemon seed
because we've not we've not lemon seeds
yeah we've not heard
are we not heard from Elijah or Sean in
regards to League of Legends we've chat
to them about other stuff but they've
both completely backed off Elijah sent
us a thing about a vegan restaurant
Ethiopian food but in no way did they
mention the League of Legends I think I
mean sooner or later we're right we're
trying as hard as we're getting to shame
the two of them to play and that's not
what any suggestions as to how we get
them to play let us know I thought a
friend of mine who uh I was uh on stage
with in in London Ed
as you may have met him you were
marvelous no anyway have you seen his
banquet it has moved to Canada and he
said listening to the Friendship onion
he said I'm going to download that
League of Legends and I'm going to have
a go let's do it he done it he wrote to
me he said he died a hundred times but
they won and he loves it let's do it but
then I got to send them tips brilliant
me yeah I was like oh stay under the
tower oh just not their Tower no no the
first 10 minutes just get minions yeah
so he did all this brilliant bills I
feel I felt like it that's a powerful
our friend will who went down Nigel and
I went down to see in Oceanside also
downloaded the game had a lot of
questions but we didn't want to get into
it with all of the other beautiful
people at the party we didn't want to
kind of cramp the style so we said let's
talk about it later but he's in as well
so we will figure out we don't need
Frodo and Sam no do we yeah we do
actually we might do I would love to
only play but yeah we do have a guest
today a very very special guest my
friend Dominic I'll do a little
impression which only you will know
whether it's accurate or not or maybe
his wife would would say don't do an
impression of his wife
our guests today kind of talks like this
he's a very well spoken New Zealander
born in the UK though bought in the UK
and also we were saying uh before the
show
very excited about most things
lovely a very passionate wonderful
artist we have today yeah we have Mr
Richard Taylor of wetter workshops
Richard Taylor who alongside his wife
are the founding inspiring members of
wetter which is arguably the best
special effects company in the world
certainly one of the busiest certainly
one of the biggest and has done such
films as William
the Lord of the Rings trilogy three uh
The Hobbit trilogy six uh mastering
Commander one should have been more you
were marvelous
um
Avatar
seven with about 12 to come they they're
Amazing Taylor and his company created
all the props costumes Prosthetics
Miniatures and weaponry for Jackson's
epic the Lord of the Rings and that
particular Workshop where they do
physical effects which are obviously the
things that you can you know see and
touch and grab hold of like hobby ears
and Hobbit fee and armor and things like
that alongside digital effects that you
can't grab hold of but you can still see
like armies and things like that and
Miniatures that that whole Workshop
situation
is such an inspiring place to not only
work but for us as a cast just to go and
and visit like this you turn any corner
and the greatest artist that you've ever
seen is sculpting a little cabbage that
maybe you're holding and yeah or you
walk into a room that's like the size of
a football field and there's minis
tariff like completely Menace tariff and
miniature form carved every window
curved so they can get a camera that
flies in it's ah they are and and WETA
is incredible and I'm very excited to
speak to Richard so it's been a little
while and he's such a wonderful
passionate uh just talented guy yeah so
attached to that joyful
inspiring I'm a Creator kind of vibe
right should we get him on the TV now we
get him on shall we do it John
Billy you and I have been drinking quite
a lot of liquid IV recently haven't we I
like it Dom and in the summer and you
know how hard it's been here oh I like
to get one first thing in the morning I
know that I've hydrated after a good
night's sleep yeah it's really nice if
you're feeling maybe a little slow in
the morning you need something to wake
you up not only does it have watermelon
but it also has a strawberry and a lemon
and lime flavor for your delication well
I love the lemon and lime that's it give
me that all day super tasty stuff uh and
also an acai berry and passion fruit
flavor as well I think at the moment the
strawberry is my all-time favorite
flavor it's got five essential vitamins
more vitamin C than an orange and as
much potassium as a banana and of course
it's much healthier than all your sugary
sport drinks there's no artificial
flavors or preservatives and less sugar
than an apple wow so grab your liquid IV
in bulk nationwide at Costco or you can
get 20 five percent off when you go to
liquid iv.com and use the code onion at
checkout that's 25 of anything you order
when you get better hydration today
using promo code onion at liquid iv.com
hey Dom you know those mornings when
you're waking up and you're feeling a
bit anxious or you've got a nagging pain
you know like my knee sometimes or maybe
at night you're feeling a bit oh I can't
get to sleep I tell you what will help
you there Dom feels CBD if you're new to
CBD Fields offers a free CBD hotline to
help guide you through the discovery
process yeah they have a hassle-free
membership program that is guaranteed to
help you feel your best month after
month or they'll give you your money
back that's simple fantastic feels it's
premium CBD delivered directly to your
doorstep you just place a few drops of
feels under your tongue to feel the
difference within minutes and of course
there's no hangover and there's no
addiction to CBD yeah fantastic joining
the fields monthly membership makes your
self-care easy you'll save money on
every order and you can pause or cancel
at any time start feeling better with
feels but come a moment today a by going
to feels.com slash onion and you'll get
50 of your first order with free
shipping that's f e a l s.com slash
onion to become a member and get 50
automatically taking off your first
order with free shipping
fields.com slash onion
hello everyone
hello Richard how's it going I miss you
good to see you
yeah yeah lovely to catch up thank you
for inviting me on and it's lovely to
talk to everyone that uh listens in and
really nice to see you both it's been a
very long time yeah too long and you
haven't changed at all Richard well well
fatter and older I think would be fair
to say
that's us that's us yeah no less
enthusiastic and uh certainly still uh
loving getting to work in the morning so
that's a good thing well that's
fantastic and we definitely want to talk
about wetter obviously what what what
time is it in New Zealand right now so
about six o'clock I think oh I know so
no uh 7 13 it is right now uh you've
you've probably been working for about
three hours already yeah yeah no no
actually Tanya actually came and jabbed
me in the ribs and said you've got to
get out of bed quick you're going to be
late so luckily only have 10 minutes
from work so uh yes I almost got here on
the spot so that's good now how busy is
wetter right now with wetter being one
of the most successful busiest studios
around how's the how's the work detail
currently uh it's been wonderfully busy
here at the wetter Workshop
um uh we've been crazy actually because
of because New Zealand has stayed mostly
clear of covert a lot of filmmakers have
come down to New Zealand so that's meant
that uh the country has stayed pretty
busy but we likewise even with outside
contracts have stayed pretty good we've
also been making our own work we uh
right through last year we built a uh a
large location-based experience in
Auckland called wet a workshop Unleashed
and that that sort of filled in any gaps
that we may have had uh and kept our our
team well employed and super busy so
does that mean when people come to New
Zealand now maybe to visit their
locations that's something else that
they can go and see in Auckland yeah
exactly it was all a great idea
pre-covered of course we actually
started at the beginning uh of the year
but um
sadly when covert hit we'd already
borrowed the money and begun the process
and we had a very hard decision to go
one way or the other but we decided to
carry on uh you know we Tanya and I
thought about it very very hard and
decided if if we bailed on something
like this then we're really not putting
our confidence into New Zealand sort of
bursting back into the tourist scene and
uh we felt it was important we played
our part so we carried on and uh at in
in early December we opened the doors
it's called where to Workshop Unleashed
a Fantastical film effects experience so
it's a sort of an hour long walk through
of this tour a tour guide LED
walkthrough of this crazy fictitious and
Fantastical Workshop filled with
spaceships and robots and monsters and
dinosaurs and creatures and so it's
people people have enjoyed it it's great
because New Zealand the Auckland
visitors have embraced it and we've had
a lot of people through and a lot of
lovely comments and it's it's at its
heart it's my desire to try and Inspire
the love of creating with your hands uh
you get to make sculpture and you get to
draw and you get to do things physically
with your hands that otherwise you may
have lost the love of or try and Inspire
it in kitties trying to get kitties off
these things yeah yeah so yeah so that's
what it's about and it's uh it it was a
joyous project for
um myself and my colleagues to build
because it felt like we were giving
something very special back to the
people
of New Zealand that love uh the creative
process so uh
um we're very proud of it and very much
enjoy uh running it here in New Zealand
that's very cool Richard so with that in
mind let's let's back up a little bit
and maybe kind of ask you about the
Richard Taylor between the ages of
let's say 8 to 11. the Young The Young
Richard Taylor who is clearly not
anywhere near devices since they didn't
exist at that point but immersed in
model making and creatures and all that
kind of stuff what what were the things
that inspired you to go on this path to
now be at the Forefront of all this
currently
uh well interestingly because I was
growing up in rural uh New Zealand in
the 19
70s which is how old I would have been
back uh the the years that would have
been at that age uh obviously there was
no access to uh to the sort of media
that we have access to today there were
no magazines on what we do for a career
that I was aware of uh we did go into
town
um the first movie I ever saw was Torah
Torah Torah when I was six years old and
then at eight years old I think I saw
the Aristocats which uh had a big impact
on me and we we were going into town
once a year to go to the movies which
was a decent Drive Away up into Central
Auckland
um but at that age I was into paper
mache model making I was really
passionate about
um
just doing model making in my bedroom my
dad and I had built a hose gauge Railway
so doing the Landscaping on that it was
time he was no bigger than the piece of
table I'm sitting at but I got really
into that and uh I discovered that there
was a creek on the back of the farm this
is a very well-worn story and I
apologize to your listeners but I only
have one life and this is it and I
started digging clay out of the wall of
the creek and that's where I discovered
my love of sculpting I found some
pictures a little while ago of me in the
lounge of this share milkers Cottage
that we lived in uh where we were
renting off a local farmer and um the uh
those sculptures are in the background
in that photograph it's quite bizarre
and uh
one of the first pieces of literature
that uh sort of inspired my imagination
was Rupert the bear I don't know if you
guys are yeah of an age that you would
remember Rupert yeah if you remember
Rupert would go through portals into
other worlds and uh characters would
come through into his world and those
stories were just so what wonderfully
inspiring to me
um I still have Rupert
um memorabilia hanging on the wall of
our house today but um it was actually
my mum was training at a teacher's
training college and the library at the
training College was having a closing
down sale and I I bought two things at
that uh at that closing down sale this
was when I was about 12 years old for
two dollars I bought a dog-eared copy of
the trip Touch Of The Garden of Earthly
Delights by Hieronymus Bosch and uh you
you will undoubtedly know the painting
if not by name if you were to see it
it's got It's Got Heaven Earth and hell
and it's got The Descent of Man into
hell and uh or or it's it's suggestive
of what um if we were to sin what would
become of us and there are iconic images
today within it that you see on
merchandising Etc but for me I hung that
above my bed and uh I would look at that
painting every day and that painting
this this was done hundreds of years ago
but when you look at the ideas within
the painting there's some incredibly
contemporary ideas as terrifying as
almost any horror movie made today and
that started the cogs of my brain
working around the Fantastical running
in parallel to our ordinary lives and I
started to realize that if I could
imagine I could visualize a life in
parallel that you could dip in and out
of through your imagination and that
very significantly catalyzed
my brain standing to think about a
future
um uh of doing this only a year later I
met Tanya when I was 13 and we even at
that early age started to talk about
um maybe doing a future making things we
didn't even know the film industry
existed in New Zealand I still thought
that people were filming local TV shows
and in people's houses I never even
comprehended sets but uh our our the the
our vision could really only scale to
theater Tanya was in Repertory Theater I
was doing
um the theater design for our school
plays at the school I was going to uh I
was actually acting the only female
parts in the school plays because they
had long legs and I was at a boy school
so I used a sport a pair of fishnets and
high heels red chair the school play oh
yeah
um so that that sort of and then of
course in that very early age I
discovered The Hobbit I first read The
Hobbit and um that that was my
um lens into Tolkien was through The
Hobbit I'm very glad it was because my
reading age was very poor and at that
young age I was reading Judge Dread
Comics
um yeah ABC Warrior Etc uh the strontium
dogs those were the um
Foundation of my reading pleasure
embarrassingly uh but um but I improved
enough to read The Hobbit and uh that
was it of course and here we are talking
to funnily enough yeah uh yeah
was there something in those formative
years Richard that you actually made
that you thought oh I I actually am
quite good at this when when you got the
finished article
yeah no I no I never thought GI might be
quite good at this but I did think gee I
I I really not only enjoy this
if I don't do this I am miserable and uh
it it dawned on me very early and I kept
that to myself my mother was a science
teacher my father was an engine is an
engineer
um and uh so they're a very pragmatic
pair
um we started building a house when I
was I think about 11 years old my mum my
dad and I almost entirely
um handmade together it took us five
years
um and uh that was a very foundational
training and what I did and and what I
do today sorry but I realized while
building that house and I did not always
enjoy it of course because my friends
are off um going into town and going to
concerts and things like that and I was
stuck in the weekends building this
bloody house with my parents but um but
I do I did identify back then that I
just really loved building things and
making things and work more than that I
had a almost unquenchable insatiable
desire to do it and if I wasn't doing it
I felt wrong in myself so my parents
wondered me to become an orthodontist
because they could see that I had
High a high level of skills to make tiny
things I was making tiny toy soldiers
and airbrushing things and so on and so
they
that that's where they thought I could
and it wasn't that they were being
negative towards me and my love of art
they just couldn't visualize any future
in the Arts at that point so they were
trying to be highly supportive of
something I could do yeah but I just
knew in my heart that I had to do a
career that made that was making things
and that I the only person I would tell
was Tanya my my future wife yeah this is
what I wanted to do and thankfully she
was supportive and here we are today
Tom I have found a fantastic new
clothing company tell me viori oh vioria
A New Perspective on performance apparel
perfect if you're sick inside of all
that old workout gear and not only just
for workout I wear them all the time
like the the jogging pants are so
comfortable yeah I can attest to that
because we've been hanging out at
weekends and you're barely out of them
and you look very spelled in them as
well I love them and also they've got
surf shorts that are fantastic they look
amazing they feel amazing they've got
nice little touches like they've got a
little zip pocket so I've got my car key
I put it in there safe as houses lovely
happier on a healthy Planet the Yuri is
100 offsetting their carbon footprint
they're also reducing and offsetting 100
of their plastic footprint from 2019 and
Beyond the utilizing better sustainable
materials for their products empowering
your best active life that is fantastic
viori is an investment in your happiness
for our listeners they are offering
twenty percent of your first purchase
get yourself some of the most
comfortable and versatile clothing on
the planet at viori.com onion that's
v-u-o-r-i.com slash onion not only we
receive 20 off your first purchase but
enjoy free shipping on any us orders
over 75 and free returns go to the Yuri
clothing.com onion and discover the
versatility of the URI clothing
now Billy yeah you and I both have an
expressvpn account we both do a lot of
international travel yep flying through
airports actually flying on planes but
walking through air yes yes and staying
in hotels with their Wi-Fi yes so when
you're using a public Wi-Fi spot you
want to be covered so that people can't
hack into your details because there's a
lot of tech hacking going on and the VPN
account stops that from happening yeah
you may be on doing your online banking
putting in passwords you don't want
everybody seeing that you need to
express VPN to create a secure encrypted
tunnel between your device and the
internet so people can't steal your
stuff absolutely just fire the app and
click one button it works on phones
laptops even routers you guys might call
them routers so everyone who shares your
Wi-Fi can be protected secure your
online activity today at expressvpn.com
onion and get an extra three months free
that's e x p r e s s v p n.com slash
onion
expressvpn.com slash onion
I think that's uh I think that's an a
normal story here isn't it from a lot of
people who are involved in the Arts is I
think parents have a fear about their
kids going into art because they feel
like there's always going to be
disappoint and obviously you don't want
your your children to be disappointed so
they try to support but steer you in a
way that this will be a more secure way
of making a living and and living
through your life so I think that's a
normal thing for parents to do so did
you take that love of art into college
is that where you went next after you
removed the fishnets of course yes I did
that interestingly the school that I
went to didn't have an art class even
though it's the oldest school in New
Zealand yeah so
um to do art through Secondary School uh
thankfully a teacher arrived at the
school Mrs Burrows who kindly embrace my
love of Art and almost in parallel with
me we developed the art class and that
took me right through to the end of the
seventh form and then I applied to
Wellington Polytechnic
um and uh I didn't get in I was
devastated because it meant Tanya and I
had both agreed to move to Wellington
and Tanya did get into Victoria
University to study and I didn't get
into Wellington politics I simply wasn't
good enough my portfolio I'd started the
portfolio too late and um and that's a
whole story in its own right but anyway
I I didn't get in but but three days
before the course was supposed to start
the head of school phone me and he said
someone's dropped out you were the 37th
person of 36 people do you want to move
do you want to still take up the course
and they said yes thank you and I moved
to Wellington uh to join Tanya I thought
I was going to spend another year on the
farm doing hay making and trying to lift
my skills and so on I was doing hay
making in the Summers I was working at
the
at the Auckland Airport cleaning toilets
on the international airplane flights is
a job that my dad had got me and I was
working at a local packing case Factory
operating a nail gun and uh that that
was what I was visualizing I'd do for
the next year but um thankfully I got
enzyme moved down to Wellington three
days before the or two days before the
course started and what was the course
called what was it called the course oh
it did visual communication and design
at what was called Wellington Polytech
which is now known as messy uh
University yeah and probably the highest
number of people that join us here at
the workshop are from that course right
that and the industrial design course I
had intended to do industrial design and
that's what I applied for but I got into
the end of the wrong queue and just
never said anything so I ended up thing
three years of graphic design and
looking back I was very pleased that
that mistake was made
um I was a bit I was a bit um
uh a little quieter than I might be
today so it wasn't one to speak up but
um but anyway it was it was a great
three years and I got to meet some
lovely people and uh associate with some
amazing inspiring individuals so uh yeah
and I just discovered at we discovered
our love of Wellington yeah that first
year we thought would move straight back
um up north again uh but within a year
Wellington you know the bug of
Wellington bites you and you know that
you're addicted for the rest of your
life so we've we've never moved further
than 15 minutes drive from where we did
our studies wow yeah it's an extremely
compelling City yeah excuse me and and
at what point at what point during that
process did your paths cross with Pete
uh
uh yeah that that's obviously the most
joyous
um moment my so Tanya and I uh we left I
finished my Polytech course it was a
course in uh visual communication and
design but I realized very early on in
that course that my illustration skills
were poor comparatively to some of my
colleagues so I started doing everything
in 3D sculpting and model making playing
to my strengths and very thankfully the
tutors allowed me to do that so when I
finished the course
um I actually got a job working in a
design studio designing children's games
and it was a very well paid job but six
weeks in I went to the owner of the
company and politely asked if I could
finish up because it just wasn't
fulfilling my love of making things as I
had just as I managed to nurture through
Polytech and I moved uh to a
significantly lower paid job working at
a local television Studio painting
ultimate Flats I don't even think
ultimate exists in the world today but
but that job quickly allowed me to
accelerate my career as I started doing
low-cost TV commercials documentary
low-cost documentary work until they
finally decided that the company decided
they wanted to do a New Zealand version
of spitting image that wonderful uh
Peter fluck and Roger Moore television
series
um and um and that that in its own I
might mention a little story there but
uh the um
Tanya and I I heard that they wanted to
make this TV series so I actually went
and borrowed a photograph of the boss
and uh a guy called Dave Gibson one of
New Zealand's great uh television
entrepreneurs and um and you know
instigated a lot of the TV industry here
and I I manufactured a puppet uh in our
flat uh from that photograph I sculpted
a margarine I was doing margarine Buffet
sculptures at night for the chef where
my wife was now working in the evenings
as a duty manager at a hotel and so I
had become very proficient in sculpting
margarine and I've swapped the sculpture
for a meal uh because we were a bit on
the bones of our ass at that time
um and uh and that TV show came out
Peter saw it on telly I think this was
about four to five years into our
working career and uh through a mutual
friend cam
he came and visited a studio where we
were making a TV commercial for the
vultures Coffee Bean commercial and it
was a sort of an Indiana Jones had just
come out and it was an Indiana Jones
type ripoff TV commercial and we were
doing these massive this massive jungle
uh with Cameron Tanya and I and this
young chap 27 years old I think Pete was
at the time walked in through the door
and I glanced sidewards and I saw him
come in and I we we were organized to
meet so I climbed off the set
uh went and said hello and that was it
uh we became the three of us became firm
friends and for the next many years
would hang out uh
talking of things we aspired to do in
the future movies that we wanted to make
he obviously
very kindly introduced us to
the world of of effects and filmmaking
at a level that we didn't even begin to
understand I I came to a love of
filmifix late late in my life
comparatively to say my American
colleagues who um who grew up on it
almost from birth so that that was great
we used to go and sit in the front room
of Peter's tiny little cottage probably
the smallest house in Wellington when he
first moved him to town from his mum and
Dad's house having finished bad taste
and we would watch this giant television
screen it's probably a postage stamp
compared to screens today but um him
Peter Tanya and I would sit on this
couch and if he left the curtains open
you'd do this and you'd look back behind
where Peter was sitting and and people
walking their dogs would have gathered
on the pavement watching the movies
so peculiar and strange with the things
that we used to watch that's great
would you say that based on your
upbringing Pete stop bringing Tanya's
upbringing was it would it be fair to
say that you guys all kind of found
Kindred Spirits in each other is that
what was going on there yeah yeah
exactly I think he was surprised I don't
want to put words in Pete's mouth but if
I record food he was probably surprised
to discover that there were other people
in the country doing exactly what he did
remember at that time
um he was making everything himself uh
he had made most a bad taste himself and
you could argue that if Peter had a
thousand years he could make Lord of the
Rings himself it's such as his skills
across such a broad spectrum of uh
capabilities and uh so we would read his
um fangoria magazines with readers cine
fantastique magazines would sit on his
couch watching strange and peculiar
movies uh we would talk about Ray
harryhausen we'd talk about Rick Baker
Dick Smith uh some of the greats of the
industry that we uh that we loved uh
together and uh and we talked about
things we wanted to make and we used to
do model making sessions together uh Etc
and Tanya been a fabulous cook would
cook for Pete Pete would cook for us
he'd come to our place for for
um barbecues it was just a really nice
way to to find communal interest in what
we all love to do and then of course he
got branded off the ground and uh that
gave us something to focus on
um sadly for us brain dead fell over uh
six or eight weeks after we joined the
production but uh very thankfully for us
um very and very quickly him and Jim
Booth the producer that we were all
working with and a very dear and close
friend to Peter
um managed to get meet the feebles up
and running
and uh and that certainly gave us
something to Rally around and uh follow
Peter's vision and extraordinary talents
uh as we uh as we begun on that film and
that is a fantastic film and I suppose
the the perfect one for you guys to work
on together
at that time because it used both your
skills so well
yeah it really was
um the the puppet production was run by
Cameron chiddick and Cameron had been a
great friend of Peters and helped Peter
at the end of bad taste and Cameron's
the same age of me but was uh an
enthusiastic model maker from Auckland
uh who had moved to Wellington to work
with Pete and uh he led us into this
world of uh foam rubber puppets and
Peter would come in and um and make
puppets himself he made Abby bhagwat who
was the uh Indian contortionist who
performs yeah fools and Pops his head up
his own bottom
but and Peter Peter aspired to make many
more of the puppets but he was just so
busy trying to get the film made and
writing the script and so on I just make
one comment on uh on Peter with respect
to that movie
it was at that time that it dawned on me
um
I think it's I think it's an appropriate
word to use the genius of the filmmaker
that we were interacting with because on
a particular evening we turned up at his
house for dinner or something or to talk
about the movie and he was lying on the
couch with his eyes closed
and he was
um talking through the film in his mind
now if you think about how you make a
puppet movie you have to pre-record all
of the dialogue and all of the Beats of
the movie before you film the movie
because you've got to play the playback
so that the puppeteers can work their
hands to the sound of the voices so
unlike a traditional movie where you
where you pre-write the script but then
you go in each day and you can play with
the pacing relative to how you direct
the actors voices you have had to have
pre-directed it entirely in your head
and it dawned on me that he was able to
scope the complete film in his mind
right down to the accents of how the
characters would talk yeah and how they
would interact and the time that that
they would need to walk from here to
here before they delivered the next
slide right yeah if you if you start to
think about it it is mind-bending yeah
when you actually start to think about
that and a lot of people would watch
Meet the feebles and go oh it's just a
silly you know piss take of the hensons
and it's just a a gross funny puppet
movie but you actually watch it and and
realize how clever it is for a young
filmmaker to have made it the techniques
that he used the invention that is in
within it uh the the clever he sent it
to new line at the time and I remember
him telling us that one of the new line
people that got back to him and said oh
God you know Richard we love the movie
uh it's like Peter we love the movie it
was amazing uh specifically the
technique that you used to shoot the
flying fly how on Earth you pulled such
a good mat off the blue screen on the
wings of the fly it was perfect you guys
are doing great Optical work down there
it was a a fishing rod with a fishing
line dangling to the middle of this fly
with a 10 remote control car mechanism
flapping its wings as someone guided it
through the scene and it was glorious so
but but
um the last couple of days ended up just
with Peter with his bollex on his
shoulder with one Mongoose on his hand
here with Tanya and I with that with
four mongooses on our hands running
through the arosh arrow street bush and
uh we're like it doesn't get better than
this and I think
Kate saw our sort of unabashed
enthusiasm and just desire to make cool
things and uh yeah and and be along for
the right so thankfully brain dead came
around the corner straight after that
amazing stuff from Richard absolutely
incredible great chat we were so excited
that we just kept talking and talking so
I think we're gonna split it into two
weeks right yep and we'll get some more
of Richard next week so please tune in
to the Friendship onion next week don't
forget to send your uh questions and
comments and everything to the
Friendship onion at casmedia.com And
subscribe yes rate review and
subscribers if you subscribe to the
friendship on you don't need to go look
for it it just shows up in your phone
and also if you review us Billy and I
scroll through all these reviews and the
ones that we love we tend to take a
screen grab of and put up on our social
media and maybe we'll even mention them
on the podcast so rate review
subscribers and we'll see you next week
see you next week on the Friendship
onion bye-bye
[Music]